screening for colorectal cancer means
looking for signs of cancer in your
large intestine before you have symptoms
screening can help find cancer at an
early stage this can make treating it
easier because the cancer might not have
spread
screening for colorectal cancer is
recommended for everyone beginning at
age 45.
you may need screening earlier and more
often if you or your family has a
history of colorectal cancer or diseases
that inflame your bowel
some tests screen for colorectal cancer
by looking inside your large intestine
these tests include sigmoidoscopy
colonoscopy and colonography
a sigmoidoscopy views the lower third of
your large intestine using a camera on
the end of a flexible tube
the tube is inserted through your anus
into your large intestine
to look for polyps and other signs of
cancer
a colonoscopy also views your large
intestine using a similar camera but it
looks along the entire length of your
large intestine for polyps or other
signs of cancer
a colonography also known as virtual
colonoscopy uses CT scans of your large
intestine
a computer uses the scans to make a
three-dimensional view inside your large
intestine to look for signs of cancer
other tests screen for colorectal cancer
by looking at your stools or feces
fecal blood tests look for traces of
blood in stool samples
these tests are often done in
combination with a sigmoidoscopy
blood in your stool may be a sign of
polyps in your colon or cancer
however stool blood may have other
causes that aren't cancer talk to your
health care provider about what your
test results mean
in a stool DNA test a stool sample is
checked for abnormal DNA from polyps or
cancer
if you have questions about these tests
or your test results talk to your doctor